lle 80 mille arméniens vivent dans notre
région
comment cette communauté at elle réussi
à maintenir sa tradition culturelle
notamment auprès des plus jeunes
jean-pierre entier nous sommes
alfortville où vivent six mille
arméniens
un habitant sur six parce que j'étais
enfant
on disait facilement aussi bien dans la
communauté arménienne que dans la coque
la collectivité alfortville âge je vais
en arménie pour dire je viens dans son
quartier où nous sommes maintenant c'est
un peu perdu puisqu'il ya une osmose
entre des communautés
mais c'est vrai ce quartier que la plus
petite armée nous avons parmi les jeunes
générations d'aider des jeunes gens qui
se découvre arménien et qu'illustre
parfaitement bien
tout en restant parfaitement intègre
également alors milieu français donc les
arméniens d'île de france possèdent leur
église leur école leur centre culturel
ils ont aussi leurs journaux
le principal haratch en avant et
quotidien il ne tire qu'à quelques
milliers d'exemplaires
mais pour les arméniens c'est plus qu'un
journal plus même qu'un trait d'union
une sorte de cordon ombilical
les jeunes arméniens d'île de france
dispose de deux grands collèges
le premier pour les filles auraient
ainsi le second pour les garçons du
moins dans les classes supérieures est
situé à sèvres une centaine d'élèves de
5 à 18 ans en plus du programme français
officiel jusqu'au baccalauréat
on leur y enseigne la langue et la
civilisation amin
non en 1915
durant le mois d'avril les autorités
turques décide d'en finir avec cette
minorité arménienne en qui elle voit un
ennemi irréductible
alors il ne ramasser quelques enfants il
est vrai j'ai alors appelé l'élysée les
gendarmes
si on ne donnait pas l'argent on va tous
nettoyés
alors ma mère
le couteau il est il à missile jordan
matériel dont le n louis truc
alors il m'a sauvé trois fois trois fois
ils m'ont mis le couteau pour maigrir g
ils sont bas puis ma mère qui m'a sauvé
mais malheureusement on n'a pas reçu
l'argent
ton fils - merrill a eu copie il est
moche j'ai enterré avec mes droits à la
niche au naturel à la division asie jeu
russell est déjà à sa longue et riche on
met d'accord mais n'a pu chiner des
chats gaz d'hamra n'est pas encore mais
la tati pour une aberration ramener la
tribune à bellaing québec